Some celebrities have earned a serious reputation
for difficulty among their co-stars so much
so that other actors don't ever want to work
with them again. From simple personality conflicts
to deranged name-calling and everything in
between, let's take a look at some of the
most infamous co-star beefs and how they got
started.
Jim Carrey and Tommy Lee Jones
When Jim Carrey starred as the Riddler in
Batman Forever, he was at the height of his
comedic career. But his co-star Tommy Lee
Jones who played Harvey Dent was definitely
not a fan of Carrey's slapstick style. Director
Joel Schumacher confirmed that Jones had something
of an attitude on set, telling Entertainment
Weekly:
"Jim Carrey was a gentleman, and Tommy Lee
was threatened by him. I'm tired of defending
overpaid, over-privileged actors."
The night before filming a scene together,
Carrey and Jones ran into each other at a
restaurant. When Carrey approached Jones'
table to say hello, he didn't get quite the
greeting he expected. Carrey told Howard Stern
that:
"He got up, kind of shaking, and hugged me
and said, 'I hate you. I really don't like
you.' And I was like, 'Wow. What's going on
man?' And he said, 'I cannot sanction your
buffoonery.'"
“Very few people are both a summer and a
winter, but you pull it off nicely.”
Wesley Snipes and Ryan Reynolds
Reading Patton Oswalt's account of his time
on the set of 2004's Blade Trinity is arguably
far more interesting than watching the movie
itself. According to Oswalt, director David
S. Goyer shouldn't be blamed for the way the
movie turned out, as he spent half of his
time dealing with the erratic behavior of
leading man Wesley Snipes.
“And he'd walk by his trailer and this wall
of pot stench would just just woah and just
push you to the side”
He also claimed Snipes tried to strangle the
director at one point, which led to Goyer
hiring a bunch of bikers as bodyguards. According
to Oswalt:
"That freaked Wesley out so much that, for
the rest of the production, he would only
communicate with the director through Post-It
notes. And he would sign each Post-It note
'From Blade.'"
It wasn't just Goyer that Snipes clashed with,
however. The mercurial action star also failed
to get along with co-star Ryan Reynolds, apparently
refusing to even call him by his name. Reynolds
laughed when he was asked if he would ever
consider reuniting with Snipes for a fourth
Blade movie, answering with an emphatic "no."
Will Smith and Janet Hubert
If you're a dedicated Fresh Prince of Bel-Air
fan, you're probably aware that the actress
who played Aunt Vivian was replaced halfway
through the series but you might not know
why. Janet Hubert portrayed Aunt Viv on the
show until 1993, when she was replaced with
Daphne Reid, who continued in the role until
Fresh Prince ended its run in 1996.
According to accounts from show insiders and
even Hubert herself, Smith and his other co-stars
were needlessly cruel to her on the set. For
his part, Smith knocked down Hubert's allegations
in a 1993 interview with an Atlanta radio
station, claiming she had a bad attitude while
filming and adding:
"No matter what, to her I'm just the Antichrist."
In 2011, Hubert fired back, telling TMZ that
she'd never work with Smith again.
Tom Sizemore and Val Kilmer
Throughout the '90s, Tom Sizemore's star was
on a meteoric rise in Hollywood, thanks in
particular to his roles in great dramatic
films like 1995's Heat, which he featured
in alongside Val Kilmer. But when Kilmer and
Sizemore reunited five years later on the
set of Red Planet, things weren't so rosy.
Reportedly, Kilmer was upset when he learned
that the production had paid to ship Sizemore's
exercise equipment to Australia, where filming
was taking place.
According to Sizemore's memoir By Some Miracle
I Made It Out of There, a shouting match erupted
which ended with Tom throwing a 50-pound weight
at Kilmer. Later, a producer asked Sizemore
to avoid hitting Kilmer in the face when they
got into their next fight. Tom complied, dutifully
slugging Kilmer in the chest and telling him:
"I'm never going to another planet with you
again."
Time heals all wounds, however, and the two
former co-stars had finally buried the hatchet
as of 2014.
Robert Downey Jr. and Terrence Howard
Terrence Howard has never been shy about discussing
his falling out with Iron Man co-star Robert
Downey Jr. In 2013, Howard appeared on Bravo's
Watch What Happens Live, discussing the three-picture
deal which the studio had originally offered
him.
“They came to me with the contract and said
look, we will pay you ⅛ of what we contractually
had for you.”
He went on to put the blame firmly on Downey's
shoulders.
“And I called my friend, and I'd helped
him get the first job, and he didn't call
me back for three months."
It would take another three years for the
pair to finally patch up their differences,
when they reunited at the 2016 wedding of
director Brian Grazer.